[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAHUL GANJDO:
Zomato first started
as an app which lets you
browse digital menus.
Now, we are this big
food tech company that
is operational in 24 countries.
More than 150 million users
visit the platform every month.
We are available
in 10 languages.
And on the delivery
side, we have
a fleet of around
60,000 delivery drivers.
If you want to discover
great places to go out,
if you want to order in, if
you want to reserve tables,
and if you just want to browse
food, you can use Zomato.
Zomato serves a
lot of use cases,
and that makes it challenging
for the development team
to put it in a coherent
way inside the app.
PRATEEK SHARMA: After all
the buzz in the development
community about
Kotlin, I was intrigued
by how Kotlin was able to uphold
the object-oriented paradigm
and solve many of the
architectural flaws
in the compiled time itself.
I almost instantly
recognized that Kotlin
will enable me to develop
more architecturally-sound
applications.
Kotlin provides us
with null-safety
at compile-time itself.
This is one of the most
used features by our team.
If we would convert a
Java class to Kotlin,
there will be about 15% to 20%
decrease in the line of code.
But if you take
data classes, there
is a drastic improvement
of about 55% decrease
in the lines of code.
Switching to Kotlin is
efficient and very exciting.
At Zomato, now, almost
every new feature
is being developed in Kotlin.
We, as Android developers, have
not experienced the functional
paradigm like the
developers of JavaScript,
so Kotlin providing a
function-oriented style
of coding was a
very good feature.
Often a use case
comes when we are
using code of third
party libraries, where
we want the class to
have another function.
Kotlin makes this
hassle-free by the support
of extension functions.
Almost all the new SDKs and
APIs that Google is releasing,
right now, has Kotlin support.
On top of that, the third
party library developers
are also adding support of
Kotlin, which is increasing
our Kotlin experience.
RAHUL GANJDO: Zomato is rated
4.3 on the Google Play Store,
and we've been lucky with
the support of the ecosystem
that Android provides.
PRATEEK SHARMA:
I would recommend
switching to Kotlin because
its interoperability with Java.
With recent updates,
Android Studio
has drastically
improved Kotlin support.
It is almost frictionless.
[MUSIC PLAYING]